over the years many types of unstable
elements have been proposed and named
after many glorious figures in the
history of science including richard
fineman
who won the nobel prize in 1965 for the
discovery of quantum electrodynamics
which he did with two other physicists
now it turns out that extremely heavy
elements are also extremely unstable
what we do is we bombard heavy ions
together to give a tremendous
conglomeration of protons and neutrons
which then fly apart and then we run the
videotape backwards we take all the
fragments put them back together again
and see whether or not for an instant of
time a heavy element existed inside the
atom smasher that's a very tricky
business because many kinds of false
bumps can occur in the data and one of
them may actually correspond to a new
form of heavy elements there is a theory
that says that if you bombard heavier
and heavier ions together sooner or
later you get an island of stability a
plateau where we would get stable matter
we're quite far from achieving that so
in the short term it means that there's
going to be more and more debate more
and more controversy as to what
constitutes a heavy element given the
fact that it only exists for a brief
fraction of a second did it or did it
not even exist at all that's why it took
so long to verify 114 and 116
you